Kate Gosselin through an epic 13th
birthday bash for her sextuplets but
where was Colin it's a bittersweet
moment
[Music]
13 need we say more on this week's
episode of Kate Plus 8 Alexis Hannah
Aaden Lia and Joel celebrated their
special day with a camping party which
included the boys roughing it in the
woods that's disgusting and the girls
enjoying mani pedis and some arts and
crafts but things turned somber when the
kids joined around the table to blow out
their candles on their separate birthday
cakes the photos around the cake I have
them for every year every child every
birthday it's definitely an iconic
moment the reality star mom addressed
the elephant in the room
her son Colin's absence this year much
like last year obviously the difference
is that colum wasn't there I am
comforted with the fact that my kids all
of them each unique child is receiving
exactly what they need and that hasn't
changed I've said that before I'll say
it again Cate didn't elaborate on
Colin's whereabouts but said he was
certainly missed you can't do anything
without realizing he's missing and so we
may not say it but it's always there
archery tag